what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back
with iron man yes we are you guys really
seem to love the video that we did we
were doing like the books of korvac and
the return of michael korvak in marvel
comics which admittedly
is pretty awesome but coming out of the
last video that we did right you had
basically patsy walker and iron man who
were taken out by korvac and at this
point it's just kind of recovery but in
the midst of all that you basically have
a couple things to go down the first
is that you have these kind of words
that are whispered in the ear of patsy
hellcat right pray to the one for
salvation
pray to the one for redemption pray to
the one for benediction just kind of
these words being whispered in her ear
over and over again
and james rhodes has also gone missing
now for iron man himself a lot of what's
going on
is kind of backlash because well i mean
because it's iron man right i mean like
when is tony stark ever not screwing up
in marvel comics you know what i mean i
feel like ever since the events of civil
war everybody's got it out for tony
stark he's just always making mistakes
but more so than that pepsi walker is
basically dealing with the aftermath of
all this
and the fact that she's got fractal
burns along her face as a result of the
lightning that she was struck by now of
course there's a couple
you know offers that are made by by
stark and so far saying well maybe reid
richards or somebody can tend to it and
you know keep it from scarring or
whatever the case is but the reality is
that's not really what's bothering patsy
what's really bothering her is
these voices that are kind of going in
her head now one of the things that's
kind of hit on here and one of the
things that kind of belongs to the
history of her character is the idea of
schizophrenia uh it was one of the
things that marvel focused on in an
effort to try to beef her up and make
her more interesting which is a little
weird when it comes to it honestly it
didn't work uh patsy walker has never
really been an interesting character in
marvel nothing against the nature of her
character personally it's just that her
stories were never really compelling and
so i just never really had an interest
in her at least that's just my take
anyway
you might you know find it a little more
intriguing but one of the other things
that's really concerning here for
tony stark is the nature of korvac and
it's really one of the things this kind
of hit on here from avengers 177 back in
the day which was the corvax saga right
the idea that michael korvac was
basically a regular human from from like
the future of a different universe where
the badoon had conquered everything
and then in turn because he was terrible
at his job he was you know kind of
hooked up to a machine and then
basically ended up taking over the power
of galactus
came up to the modern era and then
basically made himself a cosmic entity
right so you know michael korvac has a
history
of being this ridiculously op character
and in fact in the quarterback saga he
killed everybody
right he brought him back to life but he
killed everybody and that's one of the
things that patsy walker hits on and
she's like look i kind of get where
you're coming from here you know like he
was a cosmic entity and tony stark's
like yeah i mean
now he's just kind of an android but
there's legitimate concern here right
because she's like it was it was you
know at that point when you guys fought
him he destroyed all of you and the only
reason you came back is because he
brought you back
and that's true right like like
literally michael korvak saved the day
himself and was just kind of like no
this isn't really how it's meant to be
and then just set everything back to
normal and then just kind of destroyed
himself and wiped himself out of
existence but literally the bad guy
won by all standards of measurement it's
one of the things that made the corvax
saga
so significant back in the day but
ultimately if you end up switching over
to james rhodes himself oh you know in
the the outer barrows of new york and
essentially he's just kind of being held
captive
by michael korvac by way of the
controller himself now the controller
we've talked about him before
over the years in mobile comics the
controller basically has these little
control discs that he puts on people
and they basically bend them to his wimp
the biggest issue with this
is that the willpower of james rhodes is
high and it's one of the things that's
been hit on for
years in marvel comics that there's just
something about james rhodes that kind
of makes him a cut above the rest with
everybody else
and so while the controller has three
discs on this guy james rhodes while i
wouldn't say that he can do whatever he
wants to
he's still able to maintain some measure
of autonomy and it shouldn't necessarily
be that way
right it's one of these things where
it's kind of like i mean this guy should
be completely and totally bent to my
control under these discs
but this guy's willpower is nuts and a
lot of that comes from james rhodes own
personal experiences as well as having
been iron man
fought alongside tony stark faced off
against some very heavy hitters
some of which have the ability of
telepathy or the ability to dominate the
wills of others
and so over these years he's developed a
kind of conditioning even if not
outright mental blocks that basically
make it very very difficult for a person
out there
to dominate his will or to subjugate him
and that's why while he's not able to
completely resist the powers of the
controller he's able to put up one hell
of a fight if we're being honest with
ourselves and so at the end of the day
it's one of these things where korvac
having this kind of conversation with
him is really more of
in the end you will bend to my will and
even if you don't it won't matter
because once i've reached to where i
need to go
at the end of the day i'm gonna be able
to conquer the universe anyway so it
doesn't matter whether you agree with me
because in the end i will rule
everything right i will control all and
so what you end up having here at least
the kind of goal of korvac
is that in its current form he doesn't
have the power to leave earth and reach
its final destination
which is actually the ship of tattoo of
galactus world ship
what he needs is a kind of power boost
he needs the ability
to have the power to leave the earth and
then storm galactus ship and so what
he's done
is he's hooked himself up to what is
essentially a giant power supply that'll
allow him to tap into the city's power
grid and then drain the entire
electrical source of the city itself
into him and while that may not seem
like the most significant thing remember
one of the things to understand is that
quarterback is by and large a machine
and so this is one of those examples
where christopher cantwell's building
into the idea
that a machine that controls an
electrical grid or can tap into an
electrical grid can kind of expand that
to
its near limitless potential and that's
exactly what happens that once he's
hooked up and once he absorbs the city's
electrical power
into himself that now when when
everything goes down right the whole
ship goes down that with patsy walker
kind of hearing these words of michael
korvac whispering in her ear
she picks up on the idea that he's
pursuing tattoo and that's when iron man
really begins to freak because he's like
wait a minute did you say tattoo and
she's like yeah and he's like that's
galactus world shift like oh my god so
like with the power going down that's
when he realizes that korvax tapping
into the power grid and basically
following this he can control all the
electrons on earth right he can
literally control the earth the entire
world's electrical grid
now this is not the most important thing
in the world but it is a significant
thing
because it's like it's like having the
abilities of storm when with storm she
can control the weather on any world
she's on
with michael korvac it's the exact same
thing now being able to manipulate the
electric particles that exist out there
are electrons being able to manipulate
those on earth is being able to
manipulate those anywhere else this is
this is more or less akin to like when
neo and the matrix was downloading
knowledge of kung fu into his body
now the corvette can do it here he can
do it anywhere which includes galactus
the ship and so that's the idea is to
get there and then because
galactus ship runs on energy and
electrons in turn
he'd be able to take over the ship
itself it's basically what he did in the
first appearance that he had
when he first took over and downloaded
everything in galactus ship and gave
himself the power cosmic
and so ultimately you end up having iron
man who goes to visit hao kyo now you
guys might recall hal keon is the street
racer that iron man faced off against
when he was just going crazy and
spending money like a wild man but how
keon is one of these guys who of course
won uh is deaf therefore he uses sign
language but
two because of the fact that he is kind
of an underground guy insofar as
illegal street racing tapping into the
underworld you know kind of passing
information back and forth he's the
closest iron man has to an actual like
underworld team what he needs is
something a little more complex the
problem with this
is he can't just sound the alarm to
everybody right he can't go out to like
the the x-men he can't go to the
fantastic four he can't go to the
avengers because the condition of what
it is that michael korvac is doing is if
you tell anybody what's going on i will
kill james rhodes having to basically go
underground and seeing tony stark having
to operate without the help of like
avengers who will easily save the day
it's cool because it forces the story to
be written in a way where it focuses on
iron man in a capacity
that you don't normally see the problem
is that in the middle of all this
a way in is a way out if patsy walker
can overhear michael korvak michael
korvac can control patsy walker and
that's what happens he basically takes
over the body of patsy and literally
tells tony stark do not try to stop me
right like
do not try to get in the way of what it
is that i'm doing now of course in the
middle of all this is with all the chaos
and all the pandemonium
everybody's freaking out you literally
have halcyon who just like picks up a
hubcap walks over to uh to a fire
hydrant
smashes off the the top of it and just
blast patsy walker with water
and like that's it he's as calm as a
cucumber we end up finding out that's
his mutant power
is that his heartbeat never goes above
70 bpm
now here's one of the cool things man
that's a genius ability to have
if your heart rate never goes over 70
bpm you never panic right adrenaline
never kicks in
you never run into any of that stuff
instead you're always calm and if you're
calm you can think clearly and if you
think clearly
you can win right and that's kind of the
cool thing so switch over to iron man
after he had gotten a hold
of of how keon and gave him a list of
people that he needed and we end up
finding out this list of people
it's amazing right so you've got
gargoyle gargoyle doesn't matter you've
got skull spider which is awesome to see
here you've got misty night and then you
have frog man eugene patilio this guy
sucks but his stories or at least his
origin is kind of cool right so eugene
patilio he was a marvel team-up
character he originally appeared in
marvel team up in issue 121 he actually
teamed up with spider-man and with uh
the human torch to any any
like accidentally defeated speed demon
and then when he defeated speed demon he
was like yeah
i'm amazing and then like went forward
and tried to be a superhero but
basically had a terrible career but i
love
frogman i would love to read a solo
series about frogman i doubt it would
sell well it would last like six issues
and then marvel would cancel it but i
would love it
it would be amazing the reality is this
is a hodgepodge team man like this is
this is by no means
the goal that tony stark wanted but at
the end of the day he has to work with
what he can where he can
now the true benefit in having this
group really comes in the form of misty
night because as you guys recall she's
the leader of heroes for hire or at
least she has been over the years but
she's also developed a lot of contacts
and so these are people that can feed
her information that cannot readily be
accessed by
anybody in the superhero community it's
one of the aspects of marvel comics
that you never really get to see
explored all that often unless you're
actually reading heroes for hire or
something that has to do with misty
knight but there's a whole underground
network
as grand and great as the superheroes
are you know the avengers and all those
guys
there are times when criminals will go
underground and like
they'll never be able to find them
because anybody who could give them
information
doesn't trust them but they do trust
misty knight but they do trust luke cage
they trust iron fist people like that
people who are on the ground level and a
lot of that is built into the notion
that because of the fact that these
superheroes fight on the ground level
in the same way these average people do
that it's kind of like you know like
they're one of us
whereas when they look at iron man they
look at captain america they look at
thor they look at those guys they're
like they're not one of us right like
they're way up there they see themselves
as better
existing in their ivory tower and
avengers tower and just kind of a cut
above the rest of the world they see
those those high-level superheroes is in
a lot of ways being kind of haughty
right and so that's why you don't really
see
like iron man being able to get a hold
of the same contacts that misty knight
has now he does have his own to a degree
but at the end of the day none of it
really seems to work out and so what you
end up having here
these kind of acolytes so to speak of of
michael korvac they all kind of band
together in front of this this giant
ship and he's like okay like brad james
rhodes
and uh and like everything that we need
will be done in an hour and we basically
need to get the attention of iron man
here and so what you end up doing is you
basically pick up
with the the team of iron man right like
you pick up with misty night and all
them who basically come to this
realization that there is a kind of
power
source out in the dock somewhere that
basically had a high level of of
radiation or energy that emanated from
it and so because of that that's like
that's their source right that's where
they need to go in order to find poor
back or at the very least find whatever
it is it has to do with corvette and so
ultimately you end up having this
location traced down by iron man as it's
given to him by misty knight and when he
gets there or at least gets to a spot uh
you know kind of following patsy walker
that basically these people come running
out saying that like there's a guy in
the in the laundromat with a bomb right
and of course
michael korvac doesn't actually have a
bomb he was looking to just kind of get
everything sorted out with him and tony
stark at least
you know get tony to not necessarily be
on his side but the very least to
understand that quarterback's going to
win now this is the thing to understand
here korvax not trying to get iron man
to his side he's not trying to preach to
him that like what i'm actually
doing is the right thing it's really one
of these things of like like what i'm
doing here is going to work right like
whether you wanted to or not
i will succeed here and there's
absolutely nothing you can do to stop me
he's like i've already imbued myself
with half the energy of earth right i
don't you know there's nothing
you can do to stop me here right like
not you not the avengers at the moment
right now i'm already more powerful than
all of you i am looking to achieve
godhood and i will bring unity to this
universe that's already so fractured and
broken what this universe needs is a
singular god under which it can either
rally or it can be forced to rally it
can be forced to bend the knee but one
way or the other i will be the one who
rules everything right he's talking like
a tyrannical
dictator kind of guy and so what you end
up having while all that's going on
is misty knight and her guys who were
tasked with going and finding that shiar
jump ship which they successfully do the
problem is once they get in there it's
completely empty there's
nothing in there and tony stark
immediately putting two and two together
is like
no get out of there and like immediately
boom the ship explodes right takes all
those guys out and it's like holy sh
like it's that's crazy right like like
literally it was a bomb that was set up
by uh by michael korvac and that's the
big difference between korvac
and tony stark korvak is just that much
smarter than he is and even when korvac
first showed up right he was a master
intellect
across the universe and while tony stark
wouldn't necessarily give himself that
level of credit he is a futurist he is
exceedingly intelligent but korvac
in all of his appearances has always
just been that much more intelligent
than tony stark but nonetheless korvac
in in when he was really a credible
threat to the avengers has always been
wildly intelligent and so as
as smart as tony stark is in comparison
to the average person
michael korvac is that much more
intelligent than tony stark and being
able to outmatch him like this being
able to outclass him and just be like
you never really had a chance in the
first place like understand tony stark
i've been running circles around you
since this whole thing began
tony stark lashes out attacks korvak and
uses every ounce of energy that his that
his suit can can muster now
something to understand here this is
also an old-school suit of iron man so
by no means is this kent while saying
like this is iron man in his peak
capacity using every ounce of energy he
has and the best suit of armor he has
and he still couldn't take out michael
korbach no i mean that's one of the
things we covered in the last video
is that it's a it's a vintage suit right
it's not his most up-to-date technical
suit if you were to face off and use
every ounce of energy that was available
in something like the indo-sim suit from
superior iron man he may have stood a
chance in taking out korvac here but at
the very least it doesn't matter the
result is that it's not enough and so
with him completely and totally drained
the responsive quarterback is
tony stark's out of the picture there's
nobody for us to worry about anymore
like get on board the ship we're on our
way to tattoo we're gonna go meet
galactus and we're gonna go take over
all the cosmic power that he has with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace